>>Darling-Hammond: Being aware
of the fact that every child is
on their own developmental pathway
and will need different supports
and scaffolds is part of what the
teacher needs to be able to do.
>>Cantor: We don't only want to be
talking the kids that disrupt a class,
which is very often the case, we want
to talk about every child and be able
to see what every child needs.
>>Shaddox: Once a week we meet
to discuss student behavior
and student academics.
>>All right, Paula's going
to roll through the deck.
>>One strategy we utilize is a deck of
cards that contain each student's name.
>>Paula: Jeffrey?
>>Teacher: Yes.
>>Shaddox: Paula reads their name aloud
and we take a moment to just consider
if we need to speak about the student.
And if it is a student we want
to discuss, she pulls that card,
she puts it in another pile.
These are students that we
might have concerns about
or they could be students
that we want to highlight.
>>Cantor: This group of teachers
having the name of every child
on an index card are saying every
child in this school is important.
>>Cantor: These teachers having
such a deep knowledge of who is
in the classroom means that they
will really produce learning
and growth for more kids.
>>Teacher: His scores were phenomenal.
The impression I have from that--
>>Shaddox: Our team does have
norms. Some of our norms are
to use pro-child language, to not
make assumptions, to be specific.
>>Teacher: His ability to
communicate in that kind
of basic interpersonal
style is getting to be fine.
It's the academic language.
>>Teacher: He does struggle
a lot in my math class.
I think his--
>>Shaddox: It's great when you
can figure out that there's a link
between their academics
and maybe a behavior.
>>Teacher: I'm thinking it's time
to make a parent communication.
>>Teacher: Okay.
>>Teacher: Quickly, I've had a
really successful time with him.
>>Shaddox: It also allows us
to check in with each other,
so that we're really cohesive
about supporting our students
emotionally and academically.
>>Darling-Hammond: Students
may be showing us something
about what is hurting and what is
troubling them inside that needs
to be unearthed so that we
can help them deal with it.
So, it's an opportunity to engage
with the child's development
and to help them begin
to develop the skills
that that behavior suggests
that they really need.
>>Cantor: This simple technique
enables us not to lose a child,
enables us to talk about quiet
children, and of course focus
on children who may need more help.